ce que je peux vous dire c'est que je
peux plus vous donnez de rendez vous on
est complet et que l'on fermera autres
enjeux des appels comme celui ci la part
mme l'association des patients abandonné
à la recherche de médecins en reçoit
plusieurs par jour
ouverte en septembre de l'année dernière
cette maison de santé va pourtant fermé
à la fin du mois la raison sur les trois
médecins deux ont démissionné et les
nouveaux candidats se font rares donc
nous avons pas ces différentes annonces
dans des dans les magazines spécialisés
mais nous n'avons eu aucun aucun contact
donc nous avions trouvé trois médecins
étrangers hors union européenne qui
était d'accord pour venir sur montluçon
mais il y à la validation de leur
diplôme qui demande plusieurs mois donc
probablement pas avant fin décembre ce
qui fait que nous ne pouvons pas
attendre donc la dernière médecin qui
reste fait 21 heures par semaine donc
travailler à mi-temps et son contrat se
termine fin fin juin donc nous n'avons
pas d'autre solution que de fermer au
total plus de 7000 patients vont donc se
retrouver sans médecin référent des
patients qui se sentent complètement
abandonné était grand temps de prendre
rendez vous parce qu'on ne sait pas
quelle sera la suite mais la suite ça a
l'air d'être une situation assez la
situation assez pessimiste je pense
effectivement on a l'impression que je
vais dans un désert médical total on
écouterait dans une ville comme on le
sens où ça fait trois ans qu'on est là
on se promène de cabinet en cabinet on
nous dit je ne prends pas de nouveaux
clients
un problème qui touche l'ensemble de
l'agglomération de montluçon avec
seulement une trentaine de médecins
généralistes disponible pour plus de
60000 habitants
un nombre qui va encore diminuer avec
plusieurs départs en retraite prévus
d'ici la fin de l'année
des médecins retraités qui comme le
docteur gauvin prête d'ailleurs
provisoirement main forte à la maison de
santé mais faute de personnel les
visites à domicile sont quasi
impossibles
une véritable catastrophe sanitaire
encore moi quand j'ai repris ici le 15
septembre
j'étais atterré de voir ce qu'ont laissé
comme patient à domicile jeu
20 30 visites à domicile et je pensais
pas qu'il y avait autant de sclérose en
plaques grabataire de parkinson
grabataire de séquelles d'abaisser à
domicile qui n'était plus suivi du
président de la région au ministre de la
santé jusqu'à l'elysée la parme a bien
tenté d'alerter sur la situation en vain
à trois semaines de la fermeture
aucune réponse ne leur a été donnée